-The Trump administration
is defying Congress
over the Mueller report
as we get more information
about the President's
tax returns.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
After Democrats
won back the House in November
and promised to investigate him,
Trump threatened
to go to war with Congress,
and now we're seeing
what that war looks like.
Trump's fighting Congress
on every front,
ordering former aides
to defy subpoenas,
trying to block Robert Mueller
from testifying,
suing banks to keep them from
releasing his bank documents,
and refusing to open
Rudy Giuliani's coffin
during the day.
[ Laughter ]
"It's not because
he's a vampire!
He just has sensitive eyes!"
[ Laughter ]
And then, of course,
there's William Barr,
Trump's Attorney General
who lied about the contents
of the Mueller report
before we all got to see it
and then refused to show up
at a House hearing last week
about his handling
of the report,
leaving an empty chair in his
place, which was so weird.
I mean, for one thing,
usually when you see someone
talking to an empty chair,
it's Clint Eastwood
at the
Republican National Convention.
Remember that insane thing that
happened before Donald Trump?
An old man got up on national TV
and yelled at an empty chair
while everyone in the audience
applauded and said,
"Yeah!
You give that chair what for!"
And that happened in 2012,
but somehow it took
the emergence of Donald Trump
for us all to go,
"Maybe Republicans are weird."
[ Laughter ]
Democrats also want Barr
to turn over the full,
unredacted Mueller report
and all the underlying evidence
Mueller collected,
and Barr has refused
to do that, as well.
At a hearing
on a contempt resolution today,
Republican Congressman
Jim Jordan asked
the chairman of the committee,
Jerry Nadler,
why he couldn't just wait
to hear from Mueller himself
before getting the full report,
and Nadler
had a very simple answer.
-I would ask the chairman.
My understanding is,
Mr. Mueller's
gonna be here next week.
You're gonna get to ask the guy
who wrote
the whole darn document.
We're all gonna
ask him questions.
Why don't you hold off
on this contempt
until at least the guy
who wrote the thing,
spent 22 months and $35 million
with a whole bunch
of Democratic lawyers
putting it together,
why don't you wait
and ask him next week
before we do
this contempt resolution?
-I'll answer --
Well, essentially,
because it'll be useful
to read the material
before we have him
in front of us.
-Yeah, they want to
read it first.
Republicans must have
the weirdest book clubs.
"Okay. This week's book
is 'Great Gatsby.'
What does everyone
think of the cover?"
[ Laughter ]
And while Trump's administration
is trying to block the release
of the full Mueller report,
they've also been
in the middle of a stand-off
with Congress
over Trump's tax returns.
Democrats formally requested
Trump's tax returns,
and this week,
the administration
refused to hand them over.
Last month, Trump even implied
that Mueller had looked at them
and decided
there was nothing wrong.
-I thought, after two years,
we'd be finished with it.
No, now the House goes
and starts subpoenaing.
They want to know
every deal I've ever done.
Now, Mueller, I assume,
for $35 million,
checked my taxes,
checked my financials,
which are great by the way.
You know they're great.
-If they're so great,
then just show them to us.
You're the worst
poker player ever.
He walks around
like he's holding four aces,
but you just know
he has a pair of 2s
and that extra card
with the rules on it.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I have no idea
whether Mueller --
[ Cheers and applause ]
No idea...
No idea whether Mueller
saw Trump's finances or not,
but I feel like, if he had,
he would've told us about it.
His report was 448 pages long.
He included
every little detail he found.
There's an entire section titled
"Trump's Hair and How It Works."
[ Laughter ]
Now, Democrats had requested
the last six years
of Trump's returns,
but then, last night,
we got
some blockbuster reporting
from "The New York Times"
about Trump's tax returns
from a different period in his
life, the '80s and '90s,
when he was first cultivating
his celebrity status
as a self-made success story.
And this will shock you --
they were not,
as Trump claimed, great.
-A brand-new report
from "The New York Times,"
offering one of
the most detailed looks
we have had
at Donald Trump's finances,
during a decade-long portion
of his career.
"The numbers show that, in 1985,
Mr. Trump reported losses
of $46.1 million
from his core businesses,
largely casinos, hotels,
and retail space
in apartment buildings.
They continued
to lose money every year,
totaling $1.17 billion
in losses for the decade.
In fact, year after year,
Mr. Trump appears to have lost
more money than nearly any other
individual American taxpayer.
-He lost more
than a billion dollars.
I can't even imag--
If my 401(k) goes down
half a percent,
I need to take three Xanax.
[ Laughter ]
If I turn on CNN
and see a red arrow
in the bottom right-hand corner,
I frantically call my broker
and tell him
to take everything out.
And my broker says,
"Take it out of what?
You have all your money
in a checking account,"
and then I say, "Is that bad?"
and he says, "Yes.
And, also,
we've been over this --
I'm not your broker.
I'm an actor.
How did you get this number?"
[ Laughter ]
Now, we already knew
that Trump was a liar
and that Trump was a cheat,
who had a series of spectacular
business failures,
but these returns
are from earlier in his life,
in the '80s and '90s,
when he was touting himself
as a business genius
and one of the most
successful men in America.
I mean, in 1987, while he was
losing all of this money,
he literally wrote
"The Art of the Deal."
Based on how bad he is at deals,
I'm surprised
the cost of that book wasn't,
"I pay you $20 if you take one."
[ Laughter ]
During this 10-year period,
Trump was actively
building the myth
that he was a self-made success,
while in reality,
he was a massive failure
who lost more money than any
other American taxpayer.
For example, you might remember
that, in the '80s and '90s,
Trump pretended
to be a spokesman for himself,
named John Barron,
who would call
various media outlets
and brag about Trump's success.
For example,
here is Donald Trump
calling a reporter at "Forbes,"
pretending to be John Barron.
Specifically, he was trying
to convince the reporter
that assets that belonged
to his father, Fred Trump,
were actually his now.
And while he was at it,
he also bragged
about how close he was
with his father.
-Okay.
What's your first name,then?
-John.
John Barron.
Let me tell you
what the deal is,
just so you understand.
-Okay, Mr. Trump.
-First of all,
most of the assets
have been consolidated
to Mr. Trump,
you know, because
you have down Fred Trump.
But I think you can
really use Donald Trump now,
and you can just consolidate it.
-Does Fred Trump
make many management decisions?
-Oh, yeah, sure, he's the --
he's the chairman.
Donald's the president.
And Fred Trump is active.
He's an excellent guy,
and you know how --
They're very close,
their relationship.
The two are, as you know,
very close, as you've heard
or know,
or perhaps you don't know.
-He used a fake name
to call a reporter
and brag about
how much his father loves him.
Man, I would say
the dude needs to therapy,
but I don't think
he can afford it.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe -- Maybe --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Maybe he can just use a fake
name and be his own therapist.
"And how does that
make you feel, Donald?"
"I feel smart, Dr. Barron."
[ Laughter ]
"You are smart, Donald.
That'll be $200."
"Uh..."
[ Laughter ]
"Can I owe you?"
So, the "Times" story
covers a period of 10 years,
during which Trump
lost over a billion dollars,
and yet throughout that period,
he was actively cultivating
his celebrity persona
as a self-made business titan.
He told "Newsweek" in 1987,
"There's no one my age
who has accomplished more,"
but during that time,
there were also fleeting moments
where Trump could barely hide
that he was lying.
In fact, in an interview
that same year,
on the first iteration
of this show,
David Letterman tried to get
Trump to reveal his net worth.
Now keep in mind,
Trump has spent his whole life
bragging about
how much he's worth.
When he first announced his
presidential campaign in 2015,
he literally said the words,
"I'm really rich."
[ Laughter ]
And his campaign issued
a press release that said,
"Mr. Trump's net worth
is in excess of $10 billion."
And you know it's true
'cause it's in all caps.
It's like when you get an e-mail
with the subject line
"Erectile dysfunction medicine,"
you're suspicious.
But when it says,
"Free boner pills"...
[ Laughter ]
...you know it's legit.
And yet, in 1987, the year he
published "The Art of the Deal"
and cast himself
as a self-made business genius,
his tone was very different.
When Letterman
asked him the question,
you could tell Trump,
who has openly bragged
throughout his life
about how much money he has,
did not want to answer.
-How much are you worth
right now,
as you're sitting right here?
[ Laughter ]
-Zero idea, David.
It depends on what's happening
with the world and the market.
-I think this
is the kind of thing
that people
love to fantasize about.
Because you are, unquestionably,
one of the most successful men
in the country,
if not the world,
and also one of the wealthiest.
So, give us a figure
that we might ponder here.
[ Laughter ]
-You'll never
get it out of me, David.
You'll never get it out of me.
-You won't put a figure?
Just an imaginary figure?
-Never have, never would.
-A billion. You're worth
a billion dollars?
[ Laughter ]
-Perhaps.
-I mean, look how young he was.
What happened to you, man?
I mean, you actually used to
look like a normal person.
How did that guy
turn into this guy?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, that looks like
the before-and-after
in one of those anti-drug PSAs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, of course --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look, Trump --
Trump was never
a successful businessman.
He just played one on TV.
Expecting Donald Trump
to exhibit business acumen
is like expecting George Clooney
to do an arterial bypass.
[ Laughter ]
But this isn't
just a story about Trump.
We already knew
he was a con artist.
It's also a story
about the thing
Trump cynically
claimed to fix,
the thing he actually benefited
from his entire life,
the rigged system.
Most regular people
are one layoff
or medical emergency away
from a financial crisis,
but this guy lost
a billion dollars over 10 years
and he ended up fine --
except for the fact
that he went from looking
like the wolf of Wall Street
to a guy getting chased
by a pack of wolves.
[ Laughter ]
Trump is defying Congress
and subpoenas,
and, once again,
we have more proof
that he's one of the world's
most prolific con artists.
Congress is exercising its duty
to investigate the President
by asking for documents,
and Trump is just saying...
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-Caught me off guard
with that one.
That was real good.
[ Laughs ]
This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]